تبعد الصين عن الشرق الاوسط بما يقرب
السته الاف كيلو متر ولكن بكين حاضره
باستثماراتها العبره للحدود
رقم واحد في دول عربيه وهذا يعود لمستوى
علاقاتها وخصوصا مع الدول الخليجيه فكيف
باتت الشركه الاقتصاديه الاول للدول
العربيه
من خلال حجم صادراتها الضخمه الى هذه
الدول واستحواذها على حصه الاسد من صادرات
هذه الدول النفطيه واستثماراتها في قيمه
الاستثمارات الصينيه في المنطقه العربيه
والشرق الاوسط ارتفعت بنسبه 360 بالمئه
خلال العام الماضي وحده في ما ارتفعت
قيمته الاستثمارات الصينيه في قطاع البناء
في هذه المنطقه بنسبه 100 وسته عشر بالمئه
وبذلك باتت قيمه الاستثمارات الصينيه في
المنطقه عربيه وحدها تتجاوز حدود المئتين
وثلاثه عشر مليارا
و900 مليون دولار في نهايه العام 2021
والسعوديه تستاثر بنصيب الاسد من هذه
الاستثمارات وتاليها الامارات ثم العراق
ومصر رابع الدول العربيه
استقطاب للاستثمارات الصينيه اما عن
الاستثمارات العربيه المباشره في الصين
فلا توجد ارقام رسميا ولكن الارقام
المتداوله في الاعلام ان الاستثمارات
العربيه المباشره في الصين عام 2020
بلغت اكثر من ثلاثه مليارات و800 مليون
دولار واي كان الرقم فان الدرس المستفاد
للاستثمارات العربيه الخارجيه وبخاصه
الخليجيه هو تنوع مجالات واماكن الاستثمار
وهو ما جعل الصين ودول جنوب شرق اسيا منذ
ذلك الوقت وجهه مقبوله للاستث الخارجيه
لدول الخليج العربي
ميس الحربي العربي العربيه